you
[Music]
greed you're in for a great ride today
hi everybody my name is Errol and I was
soon relieved in college today we're
going to talk about the research we've
been conducting for the last four weeks
that's based on the New York City public
education system specifically data used
from the New York City Department of
Education we can get quicker here so
give you a little bit of background in
using the public education system for
those of you who don't know including
myself because I didn't know this and I
actually been in the system since
kindergarten New York City public
education system is the largest public
public school system rather in the
United States with 1.1 million students
enrolled eighteen hundred schools across
32 geographic districts in all the five
boroughs New York City also has some of
the best and some of the worst schools
in New York State for example as
reported by the US News and World Report
of the top 20 high schools in New York
State 13 out of those 20 or actually in
New York City their first school at the
top of the list is actually the high
school of American Studies at Lehman
College in the Bronx now how exactly our
students placed from pre-k to 12th grade
pre-k is something that's reason that
strata that's been implemented into the
New York City public education system so
it starts in elementary school and the
way students get put into an elementary
school is largely based on where they
live so where they're zoned in
elementary school zones are pretty small
did you want to make sure that you go to
a zone that's rather a school that's
pretty close to where you live and not
much flexibility there you can apply to
different schools outside of your zone
but chances are you're probably going to
get into the school that your zone 2 for
middle school it becomes a little bit
more flexible the zones are bigger
therefore you have access to more
schools for high school things change a
little bit there are zones high school
so if you don't apply to any high school
you eventually go to a high school
anyway but with high school you can
actually apply to any school that you
want to go to so if you are a medical
middle school student going into 9th
grade
you can apply to school in Staten Island
if you live in the Bronx if you want to
travel that fine you get in that's
perfect you can do that if you want to
and the school choice system actually
changed recently before 2003 the way it
worked was that high school
superintendents in each district had
sort of the power to enroll directly
enroll students into public schools
which you can imagine probably made a
lot of students unhappy with the school
that they got matched to in 2003 with
the help of Alva Roth a Nobel
prize-winning economist and other
economists that system changed in the
new system students who were not matched
to a school meaning that they didn't
apply to the school but they didn't
apply to school they got matched to
where they didn't get into any schools
that they wanted to get into went down
from 30,000 students to 3,000 students
that means that the year before 30,000
students had to be administratively
placed into a high school whereas the
year after the changes implemented
that's only three thousand two pretty
big change a really big improvement and
there are a lot of questions we can ask
with this background and the data that
we have but we specifically wanted to
focus and we were interested in asking
these questions which are how exactly do
students move through the school system
in terms of test scores attendance etc
and how do students use the high school
choice program to get matched to school
that they want to get into now I am
going to pass the torch over to David
but before I talk about that I do want
to note that these questions couldn't be
answered unless we had granular level
data on student profiles and school
profiles and thanks to the New York City
Department of Education we were able to
gain access to that data that gave us a
unique opportunity to answer these types
of questions
so David the floor is yours
[Applause]
all right Thank You ro hi I'm David and
I'm going to get you really excited
about our data so Roy already mentioned
that this will be with some really fine
data a granular data that we had so I'm
going to put that into a little bit
better perspective so we had 11 years of
school data ranging from 2005 to 2016 we
had nearly 5 million students 18 hundred
school dbn 425 of which were high
schools and then we had exam scores for
the ela math region another exam so we
had we had 13 different tables that we
were able to look at and go through
their data but there were three main
tables that we decided to focus on those
three being the high school rankings
test scores and the June student BIOS so
going through each of these a little bit
so first we have a student biography
data so over here we have student ID
scram and what this means that each of
these rows represents a different
student so each number each number is a
unique student and then next to it we
have DBM which would be a unique school
that the student is in and then a lot of
personal information about the student
ranging from their grade level in
poverty to their gender and ethnicity
and there's a lot of other columns a lot
more information in it
next we have their test scores so in the
New York City public school system
there's a lot of tests that students
will be taking so to start between
grades 3 & 3 & 8 they have to take ela
and math exam which are ela English
language arts then in fourth and eighth
grade they also take science and social
studies exams and then in high school
you take region exam region exams being
these individualized tests by subjects
so there would be like a physics region
or an English region and so on so in
this in this table we have students
individualized like a student the year
they took the exam and then the name of
the test and the scores they got and
we'll also have if they took in the
other tough like ela or math would have
those grades too so then for example I
mean okay and then our letter last table
that we have is the high school ranking
it's a little bit later we're going to
go into a greater detail about how a
student will apply to high school but
for now know that when a student applies
they have up to 12 choices that they can
make they 12 towards the schools they
can list that they want to get into
so for example like looking at this
student up here this student chose m87 a
which is brew college campus high school
as their top choice for school they want
to get into and several others with
their last choice being m12 a or high
school of art and technology and take
note that there's a lot of a lot of a
lot of cells that has na meaning that
the students didn't take all the choices
that they could so this student we had
here took some show on but down to seven
schools unless the other five empty so
now that you understand what data we
were using I'm going to go into some of
the challenges that we had so for
starters this is really sensitive data
so these are all real students and
although the student ID is scrambled we
have to make sure it stays it stays
anonymous and that way to be careful the
data and because of this here that I
included a snippet of like a really
intense contract that Jake had to sign
again is this data and then I'm so
because of this we have to keep we
weren't allowed it down with any of the
data into a personal machine we have to
work with it on an online virtual
machine so here you have our like well
this is the virtual machine we use it
has 112 gig that we were all sharing
some since we're all sharing this
machine we have to be careful about how
much memory used and how we code Jake
very kindly made a thought that would
publicly shame us whenever we went too
far and use too much here you can see
Alana using half of our machine but but
granted it was for a really important
model that you'll see later it was
definitely worth it i I once even left
my machine on and then left work so
everybody would stand with messages
saying but I'm using too much and so yes
this one this we had to make sure we
were careful and conservative when we're
making our programs and how we were
looking at data to make sure that we
didn't crash our virtual machine so in
data science I was I was initially told
that most data science projects involve
like a big chunk of the time of your
time and put towards data cleaning so
and our case in our project was no
exception so to start the data we so we
first got this data we were like wow
this is perfect we can just put it into
a model we can put it on the graph we
were basically done there's like no work
here but then after we started digging
through it we saw that there's actually
a lot of inconsistencies
so like this student up here in theory
it's the same student but in three
different years had three different
birthdays and then likewise this student
over here over the course of his student
here he switched from the Spanish to
Asia in Hawaii to Native American so
like this could be a mistake or maybe
identity crisis but either way we have
to factor for this for these anomalies
and then there were a lot of other
things too like there was ela scores are
supposed to be standardized to a
performance between 1 & 4 and we found a
7 but um so yes we have to work with
that the next part of that data clean
that we have to do was that it's
sometimes hard to interpret so according
to the New York City website this is the
official list of region exams as you can
see there's about like 20 tests that
students should be able to take but we
went through the table with them we
found over 300 region codes so we had to
really like go through and understand
what these codes meant and figure out
what were actual tests and what weren't
so like in the ten years of data that we
have one student managed to teach the
music region which I had no idea existed
and then finally we have naming
inconsistencies so when we're looking at
students across different tables so each
year is a different file and over here
we would have 2009 2010 is a shot the
science scores and social studies scores
are separate but then in 2010 to 11 and
2011 12 that are combined into one file
then likewise across different tables
sometimes they'd have different names
and we're trying to compare grade levels
it could be great or it could be a grade
level and these might seem like Lumet
picky details but the point is that we
couldn't just dive right into the in
front of the tables we have to first
comb through it understand the
information and then adjust it so we
could actually work with it and with
that I'm going to pass the mic to Terry
who's going to tell you about student
performance
[Applause]
hello yes hi so I'm going to go over
this of the descriptives about how
students progress through the public
school system first things is even
though we have a lot of data there is a
micro change okay sorry
so even though we have a lot of data
frames there's not necessarily like it's
calling that different business
all right the student is like top one in
the entire city citywide data so we had
to define how we measure performance so
in each individual test we had to rank a
student's performance relative to other
students in that year in that grade so
this isn't just based on the school
if a student is reg 40 that's across
citywide within the five different
boroughs New York City so now I'm going
to discuss how a citywide test scores
correlate with student GPA as many of
you are parents with students in the
public school system you might be
wondering at 3rd grade my student is
taking an ela exam is that really like
like a good predictor or indicator of my
serious performance so we chose eighth
grade because this is a really big
testing year so in eighth grade students
are likely to take ela math social
science social studies science and if
you attend a really good middle school
you may or may not be eligible to take
advanced Regents exam so what we see in
this graph right here is the black line
represents like the average the darker
red shades represents the upper and
lower quartile and the lighter red shade
represents the upper and lower decile
now if this were perfectly correlated it
would lie along the dashed line so just
we just so this graph is showing that
their performance and test score on
citywide exams are only moderately
related to how well they perform in
school so looking at this on graph the
first like the top 10 percent of the
students here you would see that they're
in like the top forty percent of the
citywide performance now we want to see
if early test scores and later test
scores correlate so if your student is
like doing really well in third grade
would they also be doing really well in
eighth grade so here I have three
different graphs this is showing their
fourth against the
great performance sport against ace and
forth against eleventh grade performance
so we see in the first graph that
there's a very tight correlation between
the difference of 1 year so it is okay
to say that their fourth day performance
are very predictive of how well they
will perform in fifth grade because
there's only one year gap but then as as
we progress to different ears the gap
increases and we see that the variance
is increasing like the variation in
their grades is increasing largely and
it's like going farther and farther away
from the ideal - but now another way to
put this into perspective is we took the
top 10% of the students and the bottom
10% of the students so I want to focus
on this 10% of students first and we see
that the their performance is slowly
decreasing throughout the nine years
that they are in the system we see that
there to begin with
they're almost over 50,000 students pour
in the top ten percentile but in the end
it's over less than 10,000 students so
we see that possibly there's a selection
effect that we see here that the higher
performing students are leaving the
system either going to private schools
or leaving the same similarly you look
at the bottom 10% and the average is
increasing we see the same selection
effect that these students are either
dropping out or similarly leaving the
state
so now firstly I'm going to discuss the
churn in the school system
[Applause]
hi my name is Francois Oscar we just
show you also that progress through the
New York City system so I will continue
by showing the trend in the New York
City in the school system so what are
the dropout with fog there grid so we
have by dropout what remains student
leave the system so we don't that's what
that's what finishing by dropout so we
have a really low dropout starting
quickly to seven grid but when we buy
night great we see we have a really high
dropout great rate we have like about
thirty percent of students live in the
system and in tenth grade that's a chaos
we have more than forty percent student
leave the system and only fifteen
percent that made 12 grade that actually
graduates so those student leave the
system and the dropout rate per grade is
a very important feature that Alana
Ghana used in the battle we used to
predict if a student gonna leave the
system for that
so we from that plot we can see our
student progress each year so yes that's
why we say drop out yeah drop out means
is that leave the system we asked why we
have a very high dropout rate in tenth
grade so the data set we have does that
really give any information about what
happened next
Eva but what you can conclude from what
we we can emergency shouldn't may move
out of New York City so they go from
there go to another state or they would
they switch to a private school and
another thing we fake student majors
take the GED because at that grade their
eligible to take GED and another that we
may think it's at that age to this
they're old enough to get a job so they
just like leave school and to get a job
so that's one scenario we think that may
happen and what is the efficient to the
high school so to analyze or student
progress in high school so we choose a
code by course we mean
you have a group of student that enter
for the first time in ninth grade and we
see other student progress each year so
for example we have a code of twenty two
thousand five that means those who that
enter in two thousand five and they
expect to graduate in two thousand nine
and we can see we have here on hundred
percent in a grid we start counting
those students and the next grade level
we see in tenth grade we have some
student leave the system and that we
have in 2005 that dropped to about
ninety percent document can leave the
system and we can see after tenth grade
the chaos we have about 75 percent live
so that gradually leave the system and
we have about sixty percent of students
graduate in 2005 and in 2012 we have
about 70 percent so we have a really
increase in the graduation rate each
year so that's a very good news for
doing we have most student graduates
each year
so the trend keep going up so that's a
very good good thanks for doing and by
graduation we mean student choice and
the GED local GED a local diploma or
they go to a region Tacoma we don't
really calculate that earn a GED or this
specialized education diploma so we just
can select that and reject local or
regional Omaha and to have another
perspective about the graduation rate we
try to facet it by it meet group so here
we have in the data we have for men
ethnic group we have Asian we have white
we have black and Hispanic and we can
see Asian Ave hired a demo likely have
85% chance to graduate compared to a
black and Hispanic they kind of overlap
we have black and Hispanic right here
and they have about 60% chance to
graduate in high school so from those
two last
but we can have that messages so if you
are in so we can see the the agent they
just like they have a black and hispanic
gavel will be no chance to graduate in
high school and we have a lot we try to
have another perspective we faceted by
gender and we see female have about so
any is they have about seventy percent
chance to graduate and they'll have
about 60 percent chance to graduate so
from the last two plus we can have that
a very good message if you are a male in
your black so you have on average we
have on average is six equals a chance
to graduate high school and we have
represent the those feature so what we
can take from that so we I'm gonna and
the micro fun to Alana that will make
some prediction about if a student going
to leave the system or not
so that's going to be a prediction for
one up what appendix
[Applause]
hi I'm Ilana
so as Francois mentioned we saw all
these different trends in the data
related to how students drop out of high
school so it would be great if we could
take all these different patterns and
harness them in some sort of prediction
model that if we give the model a
student and some information about the
student the model could give us a
probability of whether or not that
student is likely to drop out so the
first step in making such a model is to
determine what features about the
students we want to give the model so
that the model can do the best job at
predicting whether or not they're going
to drop out so one such feature as
Francois mentioned in his slides is
grade level that grade level
particularly grades live low grade
levels 9 and 10 could be particularly
predictive of student dropouts another
such feature is attendance so if we just
take a quick look at the data we see
that in general students you have a
relatively low attendance rate from 0 to
25 percent our have a very high average
dropout rate as compared to students who
have better attendances attendance
records from 75% to 100% they have a
much lower chance on average of dropping
out so this feature could be useful in
our model another feature that we have
is academic performance so if we look at
student GPAs on a 100-point scale so in
general students have GPAs from around
40% to 100% have an average dropout rate
between 5 and 7 point 5 percent but we
see that students have a GPA of 10 or
who didn't have any scores at all listed
in the data so we had to give them a GPA
of missing those students have a much
higher average dropout rate as compared
to the other students
so therefore when we built our model we
made sure to include these features
grade level attendance and academic
performance that we saw from looking at
the data could be highly correlated with
whether or not students will leave the
system we also included other features
that we thought might be predictive such
as poverty as an
whether or not a student is eligible to
receive free lunch gender ethnicity and
some basic features about where the
student goes to school that can help us
assess whether or not that school is
considered a good school such as the
schools attendance rate and the school's
graduation rate and thus have the
students perform on average on region
school Regents exams in that school so
with this model the model might be able
to tell us that a fourth grader with
very high tendons and a high GPA it
might be less likely to drop out than an
eighth grader with low attendance and a
low GPA so once we have constructed such
a model the next step is to analyze how
useful this model could be so over here
we have a plot where if we take all the
students and we take the models
predicted probabilities that those
students are going to drop out versus
actual probabilities that those students
would drop out so ideally we would want
all the points to be falling along this
dotted line here that if we say a
student has a 25% chance of dropping out
they actually do have a 25% chance of
dropping out so we see overall most of
our points are falling pretty close to
this line which speaks pretty positively
for our model another thing that's
interesting to note is that these dot
sizes correspond to the number of
students that we're predicting to have
this probability so we see most students
we're predicting have a relatively low
probability of dropping out and much
fewer students were predicting to have a
very high probability of dropping out
some so we have some other metrics also
to analyze the model so if we were to
have a baseline model that just
predicted that everybody was going to
continue nobody was going to drop out we
would be right 85% of the time so our
model does just a little bit better than
that at 88% accuracy but this wouldn't
really give us the full picture would be
more informative to know how does our
model do specifically in regard to the
students that it predicts will drop out
so we found that of the students that
our model
and sizes at risk meaning that they have
a predicted probability of dropping out
that's greater than half of those
students 76% of them actually were going
to drop out so that's a pretty
significant statistic furthermore just
because we have a model that can for
every student give a predicted
probability for whether or not they're
going to drop out it doesn't necessarily
mean that the school system has the
resources to intervene with every single
student that has a slight probability of
dropping out so what our model is
particularly useful for is that it can
sort the student in from highest
predicted probability to dropout to
lowest
predicted probability to dropout and
then if for example the school system
only had the resources to intervene with
1 percent of the student population so
in general there are about a million
students in the New York City public
school system in a given year so if we
were only intervening with 1 percent of
them that would be 10,000 students which
is still a pretty significant number
even though it's only 1 percent so if so
what this part is showing us is that if
we were to only intervene with 1 percent
of the students that and our model would
tell the school system these are the 1
percent of students you should look at
because they're most likely to drop out
we could be sure that pretty much all
them are actually at-risk students who
are going to drop out so based on this
the policymakers and the people who are
in the school can be sure that they're
focusing their resources in the right
places that they're helping the students
who actually need to be helped and that
needs to be helped and that they're
maximizing their impact with a limited
budget so that wraps up our first
research question of how students
progress through the school system I'm
now going to hand off to an Anthony to
address our second research question
[Applause]
hi I'm man Anthony so what is the choice
so what is the choice system the with
the with the choicest M students can
rank up to 12 schools in nu in any of
the five NYC boroughs and through a
matching algorithm the students are
paired with the programs sometimes there
are some unmatched students in the
left-knee system are they can update
their rankings some years there are
about two rounds and some years we have
about three rounds where they can match
their rankings again in the subsequent
rounds but the choice system isn't so
simple you can see there is this big
giant directory where students and
parents have to go through to find out
what schools to select one common way of
selecting schools is based on which
school is Gordon with school is bad
which is often assessed through rankings
and there are various ways to assess
rankings through student test scores
number of applications received distance
traveled and graduation rate here we
have two two ranks two categories of
rankings on the left you can see
standardized test scores and on the
right you can see number of applications
what is interesting about these rankings
is said you see Townsend Harris High
School has a very high ranking by
standardized test score and also very
high ranking by a number of applications
but then you see the Food & Finance has
High School which has a mid-range
ranking of about 200 but receives a lot
of applications and is ranked at number
eight so is the pace High School which
has a which has a ninety ranked 94 and
but is number four with the number of
applications received we have some
plausible about clock popularity versus
quality index here you can see this
school
schools ranked by citywide schools and
the schools ranked by the number of
applications and we can see that of all
the 400 high schools in New York City
the these schools ranked by citywide
schools and the schools ranked by number
of applications do not perfectly match
and that is why we have so much of a
scatter rather than all of them are like
aligning them aligning on the diagonals
and we see Townsend Harris High School
which has a high school ranked by score
and also high school ranked by number of
applications received so does the
foundations Academy which is low on both
sides but then again we see the food and
a fine and high school which is an
outlier in the system it has a mid-range
ranking but it receives a lot of
applications this could be because maybe
many students decide early on that they
probably want to go to a hospitality
management College and like to get a
head start in high school another
outlier in the system is the high school
for community leadership which even
though does really well based on student
performance has a has a very low number
of applications received now rifki will
talk about how to redistribute the
students in the system hi i'm rifka so
an Anthony just spoke about how the
ranking system works and how students
rank to school so let's look at where
students actually end up for high school
so I'm going to look at it we're going
to look at a few maps now so here is a
here's the Bronx High School of Science
it is a specialized High School located
in the Bronx and we see that students
are coming from all over New York cities
to attend this High School located in
the Bronx so the darker red means more
students come from that location and so
the school is located in the Bronx so we
see that students are traveling pretty
far to attend this specialized high
school in the Bronx
now we're going to look at another high
school in the Bronx in Turk Academy
which is ROS school and we see that this
school attracts students that live
locally there is relatively nobody
traveling to this High School in the
Bronx you see here and we know if we
remember that students can choose to
attend any high school in all of New
York City they are not zoned to a
particular school so keep this in mind
so now we have another map this is PS
192 middle school in Brooklyn and this
is showing what high school do students
from this middle school attend so the
colors represent high school and a
darker color means more students from
this school attend this high school so
we see that from PS 192 most students
attend high schools relatively close
definitely nobody's traveling far for
high school and here we have another
another middle school the understan
middle school which is toplink Middle
School in New York City they are the top
school and we see that students from the
Andersen school for high school majority
of them attend this is Stuyvesant which
is a specialized school in Manhattan and
you saw earlier that this school was the
Bronx specialized school the Bronx High
School of Science and those are both
specialized schools and the Anderson
Middle School is feeding into this
school so now that we've seen the maps
and this data is pretty consistent
throughout so now we want to look at we
want to understand why students are
these students all had a choice of
traveling anywhere in all of New York
City so you want to understand do
students maybe not know that they have a
choice or the schools available to them
and how can we make this known to them
of schools that they want and schools
that they can go to for high school so
we design a school similarity Network
which basically takes all the schools
that are similar to a given school and
we'll give you a list of similar schools
so it edges the question that if I'm
interested in school a what other
schools should I apply to or can I apply
to in New York City
so some students let's say you live in
Brooklyn and might not know of schools
in the Bronx that would suit their needs
so our network we took the top three
schools from each student's list of 12
schools that they can apply to as an
oniony explained and a school called
similar is if both the schools were
listed together in the top three on any
application so the more times those two
schools were listed together the more
similar those two schools are and here's
our network there is a visual and app
for this you'll see you later so here
are our five boroughs and Queens sign-on
Bronx and Brooklyn and we see the links
between the nodes here or the circles
represent schools that one student apply
to both these schools and the size of
the node represents the number of
applicants that this school received
throw them up in a moment but here your
applicants yes so the distance between
these two nodes represents how similar
their schools are meaning how many times
the combination of schools appeared in
our data so here I am zooming up to the
beacon High School in Manhattan and we
see that a lot of similar schools are
also located in Manhattan because
students tend to apply to schools that
are local so if we see the big in high
school and we take the network and we
focus on just that one high school the
top schools that are most similar to
begin high school would be the blue
college campus high school millennium
high school and the other schools listed
so if you're applying to peak in high
school you should you might also be
interested in these schools because they
are similar in the way we defined
similar to peak in high school
additionally the Bronx High School of
Science is similar to the Bronx Academy
for software engineering and this could
be really useful because as I mentioned
students may not know of other schools
and also schools could be like new
schools can open in the Bronx for
example and students may not know of
them for example here the Bronx calorie
of store for engineering that school
just opened three
go and they get very few applicants even
though it's a very good school because
students just don't know about it so
thank you I'm going to try and continue
discussing high schools
[Applause]
hello hi everyone I'm Tom and now I will
continue our discussion about a high
school application system in
particularly I will discuss the question
can we predict who will be satisfied in
the high school application process and
by satisfaction I mean the student will
get matched to the top choice or they
get an offer from the specialized high
school that they apply separately and
the first thing we would do is to look
at what kind of schools that didn't want
to go to this plot shows that
information and it is faceted my palm
borrow on the x-axis is the quality of
the school that the student put on their
first choice and on the y-axis is the
percent of applicants better schools on
the right and not-so-good school on the
left and you can see this has a heavy
distribution over here which means a lot
of students want to go to good schools
however there is disparity between the
brown which is the purple area compared
to a de Barros the prom applicants from
the bronze seems to opt for lower rank
high schools this could be because they
have lower academic performance so they
do not aim for very good high schools
another possibility is that there are
not so many good high schools locally in
the Bronx for students who are not
willing to travel far this next class
shows the similar information but
faceted my ethnicity again we see a lot
of students want to go to good schools
however there's a disparity between
Hispanic and black applicants compared
to white and Asian applicants after
looking at what kind of schools didn't
want to go to we now try to predict
there we now look at their probability
of satisfaction as you might guess acne
for months can be one of the strong
predictors of whether student will be
will be matched to the top choice and
this plot shows that
information on the x-axis is the
performance of the student in the eighth
grade and on the y-axis is their
probability of satisfaction again as I
said before satisfaction means you get
smashed your top choice or get an offer
from a specialized high school as you
can see here at the darker dots which
means a lot of applicants fall into this
range and these meet performers students
tend to have a lower chance of getting
to the top choice compared to applicants
on the two extreme ends the top
performers and the bottom performers
it's easy to understand that or if
you're a very good student you can get
what you want and for the bottom
performers we investigating into our
data has shown that lower performers
list the lower rate high schools so
maybe it's easier for them to get into
those schools so coming back to our
original question of whether we can
predict is an individual student gets
satisfied in the high school application
process the descriptives that I just
show you give us some insight about the
trend but it is at the aggregate level
it doesn't tell us for sure if we can
use those features to predict at the
individual level that's why we will
build a model so this is our a beacon
satisfaction model it will compete it
will use features including the
applicants demographics and performance
information about the middle school that
they attend and the high school that I
put on a top choice and it will compute
a score a satisfaction score of whether
you will have a higher chance of being
satisfied or not and how does our model
do compared to the baseline which means
you predict every student to be
satisfied our model has an increase of
21% points in accuracy precision means
that among other cases predicted to be
satisfied 71% will actually be satisfied
and recall means that 69% of on the
actually satisfied applicants are
identified that by our model so it seems
that our model is doing a pretty good
job and what does that mean it means we
have more confidence in using these
features to predict an individual
students average probability of
satisfaction and this model would be
helpful in helping students to manage
the expectations we might not be able to
ask them to change the background or the
middle school or the operations hall
with certain high schools but at least
we can let them know that if you put
these new schools and if you have such
performance you will this is your
probability probability of getting what
you want
so now roll will share some final
thoughts all right come full circle so
what is it that you really can take away
from this right these are the top level
things that we want you to consider
after listening to everything that we
spoken about today first early test
performance is just a moderate predictor
of future success and what that means at
a basic level is that just because you
performed really well in fourth grade
does not mean you're going to perform ly
well in eighth grade same for the
reverse if you perform really poorly in
fourth grade that doesn't exactly mean
you're going to do really poorly in
eighth grade that's actually very good
to know because that means that there's
hope for these students and also a
simple attrition model can help identify
at-risk students and that's the model
that Ilana spoke about and what that
means and it's something that's really
really important is that we can actually
identify the students that are most
likely to drop out and four schools that
have very limited resources this is
something that would be incredible to
implement into the school system to
allow these guidance counselors
and school administration to really
focus on the students that could need
the most help and in doing so that could
possibly increase the graduation rate
for that school and increase the
graduation rate for the entire new Perry
school system also as you saw before
there is a little textbook of school
choices and it's really cumbersome and
difficult and probably very intimidating
for students to go at it alone and
choose those 12 high schools that they
are considering going to I know that was
very scary for me and just because they
have a lot of choices does not mean that
they're going to go out of their way to
go to school in fact a lot of students
end up going to their local high school
and students from disadvantaged areas
awesome do select lower performing high
schools and that of course could mean
because they're lower performing they
might think that I would should probably
go to a school that's maybe not that
great or they just end up going there
anyway and of course high and low
performers have a better chance of
getting into their top three school and
this is connected to what I spoke about
just a few moments ago high performers
tend to apply to high performing schools
that makes sense
so they're more likely to get in there
and low performers unfortunately also
tend to get into the low performing
schools so they end up applying there
and these are really important to take
away from this because these are things
that could be implemented into the New
York City Board of Education system to
help improve it and we really hope that
the work that we've done today and the
access value in a few that we've
published could help the New York City
Department of Education improve and
provide a better access to better
education for any students no matter
what bore you live in and for better
academic success and these are the maps
in the network that we've talked about
earlier they are available online we
encourage you to check out both of these
because they're really really awesome if
I had to go back to eighth grade
and I had these two resources they was
helped me out a lot I went again like I
said earlier in the beginning I was in
the school system since kindergarten I
only spoke Spanish and I learn English
mom you know how that went and when I
when I was in middle school I went to
like versatile mention I went to other
in tech Academy which is a magnet school
for technology and I actually wanted to
draw I did not want to do tech and I did
not want to go to this school so when it
came to filling out my list of schools I
went to my gathering counselor and I
said I need help picking out schools and
she said okay put in tech Academy first
I don't know what that meant I just
thought okay fine I'll follow your
instructions you're trying to help me
and I put in a whole bunch of other
school that she told me to put in to and
I remember we were all really really
excited to get our choices and I didn't
get up end up getting into LaGuardia
High School which is actually good Oh in
retrospect it and when I got my paper
and it said I got into in tech Academy
actually started crying I was really
really upset and I felt duped and after
that in trust that guidance counselor it
was a really sad day for me but I ended
up really loving the school it's the
reason why I got into tech and it's
probably the reason why I'm here today
but it may not be the case the same case
for other students so again being able
to see from middle school down going to
where other students going to would have
been really incredibly helpful for me
because I would have been able to see oh
wait I can actually go to that school
somebody went there or similarly if I
just wanted to know which high school
rather what middle school students are
coming from a specific high school I see
oh this is a school that's similar to
mine I can probably get into that high
school and then I can move over to the
school network and pick out that school
that I'm interested in and see one of
the schools can I apply to and again I
we wish we had this we we should have
this now and I really hope that this is
something that in your City Department
of Education considers in helping their
students have a more informed decision
in applying to schools to high school so
they feel encouraged and supported and
like they meet the right decision and
before we go into questions I just want
to say thank you to all of you for being
here of course and specific thanks to
Jake and to Sid and then and will we
would be nothing without you guys here
this summer they taught us more than and
I'm speaking on behalf of you but they
taught us more than I could've ever
imagined I can learn this summer like I
go home now and I and I and I talked to
my husband I'm like I learned some crazy
stuff today I did nothing I could learn
this and I'm so happy because it really
made me see that where I belong or where
I should be using research so I'm really
happy and thankful that you guys shared
expertise and your time with us and I
hope that other students in the future
like me get to experience this huh what
if I'm you oh oh there there are also
other people who came out throughout the
summer
Jacob Matt Brian so if you're watching
exercise so alright Jake do you wanna
oh yeah sure of course do you all want
to come up where do you wanna
this work okay questions we have lots of
answers all right they're not on me okay
first of all that was amazing it's
really really fascinating analysis and I
agree I think it's going to be very
useful to a lot of people so I'm just
wondering something in terms of the
intervention for at-risk students you
know you were saying well there are only
limited resources that should they
should go towards the most at-risk
students I don't know where one might
find the data on this but my gut
reaction may be wrong is that an hour
spent with somebody who has a 75% chance
of dropping out might be better than an
hour spent with someone who has a 99%
chance of dropping out just because
there's too many factors to overcome so
I wonder I mean I understand if you
slide down that curve the number of
people who have a you know 75% or more
chances is is quite high but is there
any data you could get any way to
approach that I mean it's hard to do and
have to see what interventions have been
done right I think that one of the
struggles that we had with this data in
general with that when we say that a
student dropped out we don't know why
they dropped out so it would be great if
and if we had data that said this
student dropped out because they got
their GED or this student dropped out
for other reasons and then if we had
that type of information we could
incorporate we could change our version
of dropout to really just be the people
who we think have the who dropped out
for the reasons that we think that we
could as a guidance counselor or school
administrator actually intervene with
and do something to help
just to add a little bit more to that I
think it would be really important and I
don't think we have that data but I
think it'd be really important to look
at a school level because every school
performs differently and we can't really
put a blanket the solution to each
school it may be the case that that that
you would be better spending your time
with somebody who's 75 percent chance of
dropping out the 99% chance dropping out
but we chapter forward some type of
experiment to see that and it would
really probably fall on the school
administration or the guidance counselor
to really make that call whether because
what if there's more students in the
school that are 99% sorry a chance of
dropping out versus at 75% chance so it
really depends on the school and the
kind of makeup of the students that are
most at risk for dropping out I will add
to that I think Amy Citigroup it's a
really good predictor we can show in the
graph me and to assure we have like for
those guys for black and Hispanic there
we have a very low percent of graduation
so that's a very good predictor another
question is when you have dropout that
could be photo but I would almost call
it good and backdrop so they could
people I don't know whether also same
sort of you could have a dropout because
I actually drop out because that drop
out of this list and don't go to school
at all anymore or maybe I drop out
because I go to a private school those
are very different drop-off so to you
some of your data seems first in the
beginning where you talk about it
sounded as if they're all going to
private school but then when you show
that the students that's a really high
score from out much less that serious
all is certainly much less applause so
is there some way from your data to
distinguish these two hypotheses
this is not what you wanna yeah I can
speak to it I think there's nothing in
like 30 there is very little data that
shows like this they drop out because of
XYZ reasons we really can't figure that
out because we have very limited data we
have a lot of data on each individual
student like on their eggs at like
specific test grades or you know like
their course grades but we can't really
speak about like like we we have no
track we can't like we have no microchip
and every student is like this student
is now working like getting the GED or
like moves to like the different states
so like that data we don't have
available you know are so much of the
schools they're already looking at is
there also a way that you could look at
which school based on the student
characteristics that you have your data
set at which schools they would do well
so kind of give them more of a
recommendation without having kind of
prior of like what schools they're
already looking at is that something
that you've looked into I we haven't but
that is a really good idea but we could
feel like looking at individual student
test scores and like and seeing how they
progress in school and if they did well
or poorly based on those scores it's
definitely a good idea for future work I
let me add on to something I also just
don't think that it's very hard to like
you know identify if a student will do
well because like you know you get
different motivations with different
grades like you're poorly performing but
like you reach high schools like you're
just getting on the grind it's like oh I
want to go to a good college so your
performance like like I'm mentioning the
slide we can't really determine like
student performance like throughout
different years because it's not
consistent
ladder okay so it's a really great work
that I worry about a couple of things
given my personal experience that I
might have talked to you about so when I
came to the US my first day of high
school I was told that like by a
chemistry kind of chemistry department
like I shouldn't take advanced chemistry
II like it was you know a terrible
experience that I had in high school so
my guidance counselor told me I
shouldn't I wasn't going to get into any
hikes any of colleges and like I was
probably going to drop out of Stanford
all this stuff so I guess my worry is
one so if you are going to do some sort
of recommendation of where students will
do well for example if it's based on
historical data I wonder like you know
how do we like their advisees in that
data right like why students dropped out
it could be things it could have been
like encouraged to drop out right so I I
wonder like how we could we could think
about this I don't know this is going to
be part of my research to those that's
why I'm bringing it out but like heavy
time weapons at all it's not because it
seems right now like we're trying to
give to guidance counselor's tools to
help students which is a great seat but
I also think there's so much entrenched
bias in the school system given at least
my experience of my family's experience
I kind of wonder like how we could use
this approach to like look into that as
well so I have actually experienced with
that I was a pretty good middle school
student and when I wanted to apply to
really high performing schools when I
posted the same guys counselor when I
asked her to help me out she said I
shouldn't apply to those schools because
I wouldn't get in and so I didn't and I
don't know if I would have performed
well I don't think we'll know each
student is is different right and I
think it is important to highlight that
there might be some biases in these data
but it might also be important to just
note what's the percentage of students
that are male/female to go to the school
where's the percentage of students that
are Hispanic or black that go to this
school and let the parents and students
make the decision based on that they are
always welcome to visit the school but I
think the human element of like the
guidance counselor being biased towards
specific set of students or not that
part we can't fix that that is what it
is with the school better than the
biases of unity it's right to some of
the things that ended talking that's
true yeah whether they use those tools
in the way they're supposed to be used
is up to them I'm going to just get a
couple of questions because we're a
little short have you had a question yes
so it a little more about the particular
job I'll model so you included different
features vary level 10 is academic
performance did you look at any
covariance between those variables
before you I guess included in the model
so unfortunately as David kind of
mentioned we had some memory constraints
and some time constraints so we had lots
of like cooler features that we wanted
to play around with more interactions
between grade level in attendance grade
level and GPA that we would have liked
to play around with but unfortunately
with limited time and limited memory
capacity we weren't able to explore
everything that we would like to explore
to but hopefully booth will be able to
in future so first question what did you
actually do with the prison that change
[Music]
can you imagine a scenario where maybe a
satisfaction model could be actually
discouraging someone to apply to their
top school and we just drop like you
know we can't a special personal level
and like they're in somebody's we really
didn't affect on the larger scale in
terms of the model we would not
encourage students to modify so much the
operations in order to get a higher
probability of satisfaction
we still want students to put what I
really want in their top choices and
just use the model as a tool to manage
their expectations and it's also the
case that if in the future if students
start to change the thoughts change in
mind about what schools I'm going to put
on it will diverge from the historical
data and we will have to use the new
data to retrain our model similar
choices so if this student chooses to go
to this school and this school that you
would recommend this list of facilities
isn't that sort of anti technical to the
situation happening in the Bronx where
most students are chosen to go to
low-performing schools how would you
guys address that you're right that
could be the case we we didn't really
assess it based on that factor it was a
pretty much just to give you a list of
these schools that you would you might
be interested in if you are interested
in school a but we didn't really see the
factors like if this school isn't doing
well or if
this is the student if this school has a
low graduation rate but the student
still wants to apply to this school and
based off of this school those those
schools are similar for that student we
that not that Network just goes ahead
and gives you a list of similar schools
based on your school area that you chose
and also to add on that so although
there's a lot of specialties that
schools will have so a school be good
for like the hospitality business
certain Sciences and the best of those
schools are usually well known so like
the best use for this model would be to
put in a school that you already know
that you had an interest you like you
can find other schools that are also
good with those interests great
collaboration and great teamwork I also
applaud the person who got the data from
the people of Education at Lehman
College and I know you're presenting to
your family and friends today as your
audience but I'm wondering this really
deserves to have an audience of
educators were people in the goe
certainly the data that you present
about the Bronx can be brought to Lehman
College where we have faculty and people
going out into the field of Education
where this would really impact their
practice so if I can I will see if
there's a way to invite some of you or
all of you to come up I don't know
whether you know the presentation can
travel or who is your audience for the
future it shouldn't be
[Applause]